we need to adjust our mentality for
ourselves and our leaders like you know
it's been this way for most of my life
where the right when it comes to
something like a boycott it was the norm
Dave it was mainstream
not just from politicians from pundits
to say things like well we don't do that
and that's not who we are well that's
not who we are and then we woke up one
day and Target's telling your 13 year
old daughter to chop her boobs off and
we were shocked at that well why were we
shocked at that the corporate boardroom
was only ever getting pressure from One
Direction the right has to understand
now
that this whole philosophy of bragging
about not using power is ridiculous if
you have the governorship like DeSantis
you use it like DeSantis if you have
numbers in your local community you go
take over your school board and you make
sure your values are in your school you
use power the Communist is still a
minority but he understands how to use
power we will drive by the local public
library a thousand times you me
everybody and you won't even look at it
unless you have kids it's a public
library because the crap about it the
Communist drives by the public library
and he sees an opportunity he sees power
why are there child drag shows going on
at your local public library because you
drove by it a thousand times and never
thought about it and he drove by it and
he saw power that's why we must adjust
our mentality
foreign
Rubin and joining me today is the author
of the anti-communist manifesto as well
as the host of the Jesse Kelly show
Jesse Kelly welcome to the Reuben report
it is an honor to be here once again my
friend as always Dave yes I'm a I'm a
world famous author Now Dave I'm a very
important person now
is this your first book
it is my first book and will probably be
my only book uh the truth is I don't
like to write I enjoy doing TV and radio
that's what I do for a living but I do I
don't enjoy writing I I just they were
hounding me hounding me how to me hey we
want you to write a book for a few years
and I always just said no I wasn't
interested and then they said what if
you wrote something about anti-communism
because that's what I'm most passionate
about and I said yes that I will write
so this is my one-off probably but I am
proud of it
before we get into the specifics of the
book and the political machinations and
all of the lunacy of the day I want to
talk about your height because you're
like eight foot seven or something and
every time I see you in real life
despite the fact that I've seen you I
don't know probably a dozen times in
reality because you're in a small box
right now you seem normal size but in
real you're six eight right like you're
you're huge man you should be in the NBA
and instead you're babbling about
politics with Schmucks like me okay hold
on yes I'm six eight but I'm also on
athletic Dave I'm slow I can't jump I'm
not coordinated so those things always
have you thought about the WNBA
they put a ceiling on my athletic
achievements that's one two you think
you think I'm tall and that hits you
when you meet me and I always get this
from people I can't believe I'll tell
you I didn't realize that you know what
hits me Dave how short everyone else is
that I see on TV or something like that
when you meet because everyone on TV in
my opinion looks like they're a good
size it takes up the whole screen right
so you think now by the way Dave Rubin
for those who've never met him is tall I
would guess you're at least six feet but
but so many people I meet are just
minuscule Dave I'll walk up to them and
I'm used to this Larger than Life
personality and I feel like patting him
on the head and getting him a binky or
something
all right well beyond beyond your height
uh one of the reasons I love doing your
show and that you know we're kind of in
the same circles these days is because I
think we both have a similar attitude
about politics it's like we talk about
politics we're passionate about it but
we're also trying to have fun we're
trying to make our audience laugh and
not you know so many people are just
riling these people up and then send
them out into the world when did you get
involved in politics or interested in
politics or any any version of like what
that was about you that made you want to
do this the way that you do it pretty
late in life which probably explains a
lot including the what you were just
talking about I always loved history I
was always a reader I was a very bad
student I got a 0.0 in my first semester
of college that's real by the way I was
a very bad student but is that possible
how's that even possible well Dave
there's beer and there's girls and as
long as there's plenty of that around
you don't ever end up in class I figured
out if no one's there to make you go so
it was a very fun semester but not the
most productive one in the world anyway
but I didn't get political until late in
life I grew up in a construction family
that's my background joined the Marines
got out of the Marines started going to
community college right back to
construction that's just what I was
going to do and then Obama ran for
office and I ended up running for
congress because I was so mad about him
running for office a couple times in
Arizona ended up staying in the fight
going back to the private sector selling
RVs so I've only been doing like TV and
radio four or five years but you're
right I'm on the same philosophy I mean
I did it in the book too I do it on my
video shows I do it on my TV show just
like you do I don't like to scream and
yell all day long there's enough bad
news out there and we talk about that
very frankly but screaming and yelling
at my blood pressure is going through
the roof that I'm upset and you're upset
and that's just there's way too much of
that I don't like it
what was it that you saw about Obama
early on that probably I suppose led to
a guy like you writing a book like this
uh well again I wasn't we I always knew
we were Republican but that was one
conversation with my parents I think I
was in kindergarten Hey Dad are we
democrat or republican we're Republican
I didn't even know why so okay so it
wasn't a political house but it was a
patriotic house and I mentioned that I
was uh reading all the time I was a geek
for military history and Military
fiction and Military anything when I was
a kid just give me a book on the Marines
and let me read it so I really was
raised with a deep deep love of the
country and while I never really cared
honestly about Clinton and a lot of
these guys I knew all the controversies
Obama was the first guy I saw running
for president that I really I could tell
he really hates the country he really
really hated the country and I was so
aghast at the thought of because I guess
I probably had lost the ideals back then
Dave I was a little less created about
the presidency and who the president
should be and the Statesmen who should
lead America and I just was horrified
that someone who hated the place might
lead it and that's that's from there
I've been marching down to the local
Republican office I didn't even know how
to run for office I said I'm running for
something that's how it went
they said we'll take that six eight guy
and see if he can run let's see what
happens yeah you know you know it's
funny because I know you know my story
obviously about coming from the left and
I was on board the Obama thing and I
voted for him twice but I remember day
one of his presidency when Michelle
Obama said that thing about this is the
first day I've ever been proud of
America I remember suddenly being like
whoa what what what huh how'd that
happen it it bothered me so much it made
me political because like I said I was
not an I wasn't even active in politics
I wasn't doing any of that I was going I
was working construction I just met my
wife so I'm chasing all my I'm spending
all my money chasing her around Dave you
know how it goes and I just wasn't I
wasn't involved but I the more I read
about this guy I thought to myself wait
this guy's gonna be the nominee what
this guy can't be the president and look
the rest is history
so since the book is called the
anti-communist manifesto and I'm sure
many people are familiar with the
Communist Manifesto uh first off do you
make a distinction at this point is is
there an important distinction to make
between socialist
communist and even Democrat at this
point like how would you sort of line up
each one of those uh ideologies yeah
there's no difference in any of them so
there's no need there's no point in
making any distinctions at all because
this is this is what we do this is
actually what they do very very well to
us and then we oblige
we stress because because you have a
moral code Dave now I don't have much of
one but I have some but but because of
that there are things we don't want to
be and things we don't want to do like I
don't want to be a hypocrite or a liar
I'm a bad person but I don't want to be
accused of those things right so what
they will always do is they'll always
have you the Communists these days will
have you define things he'll never
Define anything for you hey what is
social justice hey hey what does it mean
what how do we know we'll have gotten to
equity that's surely the goal right
he'll never Define anything for you you
can't get those definitions but he'll
demand you to find everything well it's
actually not socialism because if you
look at the dictionary definition that's
that that's how he gets you every single
time none of that matters communism is
just a religion that's all it is
communism socialism now modern Democrats
it's the religion of the malcontent
that's why it's taken a different form
every country it's ever been put into
place from the Soviets it was the urban
poor they tried to do that in China and
Mao said nope you're stupid our Urban
and poor are actually pretty happy here
we have really miserable rural poor so
it's the rural poor in China in America
it's not any of that at all it's all
cultural now because our Urban poor and
our rural poor had a great life and they
couldn't get traction here so they
switched with the Frankfurt School to
all this cultural Marxism stuff where
are you gay and oppressed in this
country are you black and oppressed are
you a feminist and oppressed are you
just trying to find whatever
malcontained group they could find out
there to try to burn the place down it's
just the religion of Destruction it's
not more complicated than that so is
that is that really what it boils down
to that that because we have some code
of ethics let's say and and some
principles and they might be somewhat
different but we're acting against a
bunch of people who it seems to me their
mission is either only to burn it down
maybe with a dash of replace it with
something but I'm actually not even sure
of that I think it's just a burn it down
and that we somehow in some ways it
feels like we can't win because they're
all in on destruction and it's much
easier to destroy than to create
no no yes and no Dave I guess I'll put
it to you that way we can win we can win
good can defeat evil but only if good
understands it's fighting evil that's
another reason I wrote the book it's
part of the it's what we've never done
before again because you have some sort
of a moral code and especially because
you used to be on the left and you used
to run in those circles you undoubtedly
will think about individual friends you
have a Democrat here a liberal there who
you can talk to to this day you may talk
to them you may break bread with them
and think to yourself well that's this
person may be misguided but he's
certainly not my enemy and that's fine
when you think about individuals but
we're not dealing with bad overall when
we deal with the movement this communist
movement here in America really globally
we're not dealing with bad we're dealing
with evil and but we approach it like
we're dealing with bad like if we just
talk to him enough if I'm just
understanding enough hey we both want
school shootings to stop so let's come
to a compromise but what we've never
understood is they don't want School
students to stop I know that sounds the
extreme to people but when Dave Rubin
wakes up and sees the school shooting
his freaking heart breaks and he's
calling family and friends and did you
see the kids and how sad this is
the Communist doesn't think like that at
all Joe Biden gets together with his
staff that on the day of a stool
shooting and there's not a single tear
in fact most of them are happy hey this
is great who died oh nice it was black
people oh good tell me the shooter was
white oh yes shooter was white let's do
a statement out there we'll visit
everything's an opportunity to somebody
without any values at all everything and
it's hard to accept that about your
fellow man that that's what you're
dealing with and that's the struggle
with the right right now how do we
accept that because that's what we're
dealing with okay so how how do we
accept that then because I sense and you
know as you know I've been a very uh
vocal new Floridian I sense that the
right version of conservatism is taking
root hero a piece that understands when
to use government what is true what type
of leaders we want Etc I mean is that
the route that we have to that we need
the rest of the country to go down maybe
that uh well I made it 10 minutes in
without saying to Santa no no yes that's
what we need to do we we need to adjust
our mentality for ourselves and our
leaders like you know it's been this way
for most of my life where the right when
it comes to something like a boycott it
was the norm Dave it was mainstream
matches from politicians from pundits to
say things like well we don't do that
that's not who we are well that's not
who we are and then we woke up one day
and Target's telling your 13 year old
daughter to chop her boobs off and we
were shocked at that well why were we
shocked at that the corporate boardroom
was only ever getting pressure from One
Direction the right has to understand
now
that this whole philosophy of bragging
about not using power is ridiculous if
you have the governorship like DeSantis
you use it like DeSantis if you have
numbers in your local community you go
take over your school board and you make
sure your values are in your school you
use power the Communist is still a
minority but he understands how to use
power we will drive by the local public
library a thousand times you me
everybody and you won't even look at it
unless you have kids it's a public
library because the crap about it the
Communist strives by the public library
and he sees an opportunity he sees power
why are their child drag shows going on
at your local public library because you
drove by it a thousand times and never
thought about it and he drove by it and
he saw power that's why we must adjust
our mentality is that the beauty of
what's going on here with Target and Bud
Light right now that it seems like and
again when I say conservative I just
mean sort of the broad like roughly sane
people people who are somehow connected
to reality let's say that bottom up they
they were like all right no more Bud
Light No More Target and it's actually
working meaning they weren't fully
waiting for the top-down version of all
of this yeah yeah I think the target
stuff honestly I think the trans stuff
specifically the trans kids stuff I've
made this argument I I believe it might
save the United States of America and I
really mean that because I just
mentioned how outnumbered the Communists
are and they are but they've been much
more committed and they've been involved
so you have all these people on the
right just kind of normal people how'd
you catch the game last night but didn't
really ever get involved and that lasted
forever for the most part that for the
most part people don't care what other
people do with their lives they really
just don't and then all of a sudden
normal person woke up one day and he
found out wait a minute we're chopping
off boys penises that's something that's
happening in regular that's happening in
the country wait Disney's once Disney
wants kids to do this normal guy woke up
one day and all of a sudden there's a
on his Bud Light and now you woke
him up and that was really what we
needed all along we needed that guy who
shares our values to wake up and realize
we're dealing with a whole different
animal people here and the second you
start attacking kids I I'm hopeful that
maybe a line has been crossed that now
we're going to really start fighting
back with some teeth that's why you see
Target boycotts and Bud Light boycotts
work for the history and right-wing
boycotts
so now that we're seeing it from the
people what do you make of the set of
Republicans who've been pushing back
against some of this stuff so you know
say Chris Christie Mike Pence the
Republicans who are against DeSantis
going after Disney Nikki Haley uh I was
on Megan Kelly's show who I absolutely
adore she was kind of against it uh you
know that there's this set of people who
are now like oh we don't want to ever
use government to do things uh even when
in my view it's extremely just and
certainly within the purview of of
government
yeah well I don't care for Chris
Christie or Mike pants I adore Megan
Kelly just like you do but I'll I'll say
this I sympathize with that Dave and
this is why I sympathize with it I'm 41
I'm not ancient I know I'm going bald
but I'm only 41. but my entire kid man
conservatism more being on the right or
whatever that may be it has always been
hey this is all the power we won't use
hey this is how limited our power is hey
we won't use our power they will because
they're the bad guys but we won't and so
that mentality that mentality has been
ingrained it's been beaten into people
on the right for most of their lives if
you're 60 years old watching Dave Rubin
right now that's all you've ever known
if you read or paid attention to
right-wing news and sources that's all
it's ever been bragging about not using
power so when you wake up one day and
you walk into that person's office and
you tell them no we must use all the
power we have or we're going to lose to
some sub-human Savages it's hard for
that person to just wake up one day and
realize oh my goodness we need to use
power it'll be too far for many people I
understand that it's hard to change a
mentality but the right needs an entire
mentality change
what do we do about the set of people
and it might be half the country it
might be more than half the country that
are brainwashed and are not going to
come around to this so you know like I
see you on Twitter you're I'm kind of in
this Camp too it's like we need some
separation from these people to me if
the DeSantis thing doesn't work well at
what point are we the United States of
America if Cali wants to go that down
that road and Florida wants to go down
the Freedom Road like what actually is
uniting us but we are still one country
at least for now yeah we're not one
country anymore I I again I don't want
to be too jaded but I don't want to be
too Pie in the Sky either we're not one
country anymore and we won't be one
country a hundred years from now and we
shouldn't be that's I say that and
people get mad especially people on the
right because people on the right are
actually patriotic well understand I
love my country too but we're not we
shouldn't be a nation the only point in
coming together and living as a people
whether you're a Tiny Tribe or a big
country is for the protection and
prosperity that living around each other
provide and you only get that if you
share some common values if I believe in
being left alone Dave and you're my next
door neighbor in in the tribe I live in
and you believe every day you should
wake up and come poop in my living room
well we shouldn't be next door neighbors
we just it doesn't mean you're wrong I'm
wrong we just have different values we
need to be a part that's where we are
now we are two different countries at
least and we're already separating
people are migrating they're leaving
California they're leaving New York
they're going to Texas they're going to
Florida they're going to Idaho people
are are separating as the blue States
descend into hell and they will the
people don't even realize how bad it'll
get in blue states red States people who
want to live normal lives will move to
Red States and how that final separation
comes I'm worried about that but it's
coming it's at some point
do you think there is a rock bottom for
the blue States I mean I was in San
Francisco last week and no matter how
many times I go there and trust me I
don't want to go so it basically takes a
lot to get me there uh it is
unbelievably horrible it is not an
American city it should be the lead
story on every Cable News Channel every
night of course it never is
you know that actually breaks my heart
Dave because unlike many people I love
cities I love the country too I grew up
in Montana I love them all but I love a
city and I've heard I never got to go in
its prime I heard San Francisco was at
one point the most beautiful city in
this country I've just heard it was
stunning and so I don't celebrate when
when that stuff happens but to answer
your question I view this as being a
spiritual war as much as anything else
I've told many people I don't care what
you believe it's not my business but you
have to look at them and understand
you're dealing with evil forces and evil
doesn't have a bottom Dave to answer
your question I mean bad does if you if
you're a bad guy if I'm a bank robber
for a living I may wake up tomorrow
morning I very well may and say dude
I've robbed enough it's too dangerous I
don't feel right about it I'm gonna go
with get an accounting job somewhere bad
might do that but a demon never wakes up
one day and says man you know I'm done
with all this evil stuff I think I think
I think we've gone too far guys the kids
stuff is too far I think we should sit
it out it only goes down from here and
though places sadly
right so what do you do for the people
that are not quite at demon level that
are just that confused level let's say
you know for the people that are the
self about 19 year old Communists of
today that maybe we can do a Reclamation
project on
well I think they're going to have a
very hard Awakening on their own and
very sadly Dave they're not going to
listen to you they're going to listen to
the misery that comes one day if they
would listen to you now they would wake
up and come out of it but that's not not
generally how it's gone there are many
many many many many many Communists in
the Soviet Union who found themselves
slowly dying in the gulag system who
woke up and realized that they had
served some seriously evil people and
that's kind of what it takes to wake up
a lot of people who get seduced by that
it's easy for young people to think
they're being tolerant or nice or I want
to be loving or something like that and
then one day you wake up and you're
stepping on heroin needles and slipping
on poop as you walk down the sidewalk in
San Francisco and you realize that maybe
my life that I was that I was hoping for
maybe it was a maybe I was sold a bill
of goods and it's going to take that
level of misery for people that's why
look as as much as it saddens me that
San Francisco is like that that New
York's going this way Philly these
places as much as it saddens me in a way
I sell liberated not that I want anyone
to be hurt and raped and murdered or
anything like that but clearly people
who still vote Democrat they have not
experienced enough pain from their
voting choices yet and I don't want them
to experience more pain but obviously
they're going to have to experience more
pain before they wake up and start
changing their behavior so look go ahead
loot the next door in San Francisco I
don't care keep voting Democrat they'll
keep doing it
let's hit a couple of the other big
topics of the day right now are you uh I
would say uh let's say generally pleased
the way the mainstream media seems to be
collapsing it's pretty good for guys
like us I I do think there's a certain
risk involved when nobody believes the
same thing but it seems inevitable to me
that these guys are going to collapse at
this point yeah it's a completely
poisonous institution that's a clear and
present danger to the United States of
America I think it's a great thing it's
collapsing I I actually am not sure what
this is going to look like but give me a
second to filibuster here Dave I have
this thing I think about a lot where I
think about Society this is going to
come back to the media thing it's like a
big ball of Play-Doh right we all had
Plato when I was a kid and then you have
these Elites the media people the
politicians the professors the
entertainers they're a part of the Plato
right well because they're evil and
horrible and corrupt and they hate us
they're kind of been separated so it's
like they're this tumor on the outside
of our ball of Plato and they want to
pull us back with them so they can
continue to lead us but really
everything they do continues to violate
trust and so instead they're just
pulling away in a way in a way and it's
Getting Thinner and thinner and thinner
at some point in time that strain is
going to break and I don't know what
that looks like but when 60 of the
country thinks the FBI is a criminal
organization that's where we're at
people don't trust the media
people don't trust the CDC even five
years ago if I told you the CDC even
normal right-wing guys what do they have
to say that's that's really important
now you hear CDC go off what are they
lying about now how does that look for a
nation when all of its institutions
break away because they clearly have no
idea how to earn that trust back and get
back in the ball of Plato I don't know
what that looks like I can't imagine
it's good but it's probably better than
the alternative
isn't it kind of funny what it does to
guys like us like people come up to me
when I go to the supermarket or go
bowling and they're like Dave you're the
only guy I trust and I'm always like
they mean it as a compliment but I'm
always like we're in a lot of
trouble yeah yeah I I think that a lot
when people they'll thank me for doing
the show or thank me for talking about
this and I tried to explain I mean I do
appreciate it but man I'm an idiot if
you're relying on me to to be the only
one who tells you the truth we are in
very serious trouble there should be
like a bunch of very smart people out
there who bring this stuff to you all
the time and talk to you like this all
the time if it's me
that's not good that's not good that's
good for us I guess David that's not
good for the country which is what
really matters yeah well I'd like to
think that there's a whole slew of us
but nonetheless it's like I would that's
the funny thing I always say about the
mainstream media it's like you guys
don't have to be good just don't be
endlessly horrible uh but let me let me
ask you something else on just like the
the purely political side of things uh
you seem to be sort of where I'm at in
the in the DeSantis camp on what's going
on with him and Trump right now uh I
supported Trump every morning I wake up
and I'm like I hope he hasn't posted
anything today because that way I won't
have to go after him because I don't
want to have to go after him but if you
attack Florida if you attack Kaylee if
you attack the policy on kovid like all
of the stuff
I it feels incumbent on me to do
something what's been your policy on all
this
my policy on it is that I don't fall in
love with with politicians I don't join
anyone's team I don't I'm not on team
Trump I'm not on team DeSantis I want
them both in the primary to beat each
other up because I believe that will
give us a better candidate what I've
said is I'm leading towards voting Ron
DeSantis now because covet lockdowns and
coveted back stuff it's my biggest issue
other people have issues they vote on
that's my issue I view that as being a
crime perpetrated against the American
people and right now I'm voting for
Rhonda Santos in the primary because
Donald Trump won't stop bragging about
it he'll be he's either lying about it
or he's bragging about it we did
everything perfectly the vax saved
millions of lives these things are not
true and the American people are owed a
reckoning I'm not saying he has to get
on his knees and beg for forgiveness but
some sort of ownership don't spit in my
face don't tell me it was great when it
wasn't great don't tell me you didn't do
it when yes you did I was alive I wasn't
born yesterday as far as the I saw that
Kaylee mcinini stuff and stuff like that
with Trump
look this is the kind of thing where you
know what you ever known anybody really
struggled with weight Dave I know you
have we all know someone who struggles
with weight and they're really fat and
then they'll sleep in and then they'll
wake up and their body will hurt and
they slept in they didn't sleep well
because they're fat so instead that
turns into a fast food meal and then
instead of a workout and then you feel
like crap again and later on you might
as well just order a piece where where
things are bad but because they're bad
things snowball and get worse and worse
and worse this is what happens this is
what's happened to Trump for a long time
for four years it's happened to him the
people around him are really really
really bad he he got first for whatever
reason the guy's policies are great he's
just cannot pick Personnel at all the
people around him are awful they're
losers and scumbags and idiots but at
the same time because they're losers and
scumbags and idiots and because Trump
wakes up and does things like give it to
Kayla mcenany both barrels he can't get
good people all the people that will
want to work for him are losers in
scumbags and idiots so you want Trump to
have good people around him to implement
good policy but because of stuff like
that because it just doesn't seem to
want to control himself on social media
he ends up alienating all the good
people what what I mean Kayla mcinany
was a star or whatever you think about
her personally I don't know or if I'm
not friends with her so I'm not I don't
care but she was awesome if if that
lady's getting blasted both barrels what
talented persons go and work for Trump
again and this is why as I've heard for
months and months and months now the
talented people are saying no they're
they're being reached out to and they're
saying no I'm not interested and so it
like I said it makes it worse it only
gets worse from here
yeah there's definitely a
self-fulfilling prophecy element to it
uh what what about the the Democrats I
mean we're going to throw a guy with
dementia back up there the woman behind
him you know probably doesn't know what
two plus two is or would give you a very
convoluted explanation on how there's
multiple answers and then just beyond
that I mean the benches you know you've
got truly a communist and Gavin uh the
rest of them it's just such a freaking
clown car like there's just nothing left
there's nothing left and that's kind of
a sad place to be I I don't know about
you I would love the option of voting
for a Democrat of course I I can't stand
Republicans I yell at Republicans as
much as I yell at Democrats but I can't
vote for that what am I supposed to vote
for child mutilation an open border I
can't I can't vote for that there's no
reason there there's no nothing it's all
just March just burn it all down crap
now so I can't vote for that so I'm
stuck voting for the freaking
Republicans but Dave I mean look it's
time to address the voting in this
country and the way it goes and the
Machine the Democrats have built over
time decades and decades and Decades of
building up government forces to Aid
them in this where now you can run a
president who has dementia from his
basement never holding a rally of any
kind never really doing any serious gotv
efforts nothing like that from his
basement couple media interviews
remember when he got caught with the
prompt cards behind the thing and now
he's president of the United States of
America he can't talk you can't think he
can't stay up past five in the evening
the senator from Pennsylvania is a
freaking vegetable Senator cucumber he
can't talk he's brain damage he had a
major stroke his brain is damaged he
should be resting and rehabbing he's the
United States Senator Dianne Feinstein
from California the truth is there's no
more competency requirements in this
country now that Democrats have figured
out how to chase down the ballots they
need and now that Democrat voters cease
any thought at all they just don't like
we brought up New York and San Francisco
earlier these people will walk through
all this squalor and oh look there's a
homeless guy doing heroin right there oh
someone just assaulted my wife oh it's
election day which Democrat are we
voting for today this don't doesn't go
through their head it amazes me
I know it's look at Chicago they got rid
of Lori Lightfoot and then they everyone
was excited for a half a minute and they
voted in an even more radical nut job I
got one more for you Jesse Kelly because
I know you're a busy man with many shows
to do today so I'm being respectful of
your time when people read the
anti-communist book will they feel at
the end that they there is hope that is
a question yes it's not I separate out
every chapter and I tie up all kinds of
History into it of the different
chapters of this is on the education
system this is on corporate communism
this is on guns but every chapter has
action items in the end it's not just a
yell and scream everything sucks it's uh
this is the history of it this is the
issue this is how we have to attack it
every single time it's it's I tried to
lay it out as kind of a how-to manual
with steps we can take plus there's some
there's some humor in there as well
Jesse Kelly the book is the
anti-communist manifesto the link is
down below we shall continue this in the
digital ways that we do these things huh
thank you my brother I appreciate it's a
jessiekellybook.com thanks for having me
on man I appreciate you a lot Dave
good seeing you man if you're looking
for more uncensored opinions from
today's thought leaders check out our
media playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a wide variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell